alright kevin o'leary welcome how are
you doing by a man of your complete ban
you've been on jeopardy of one wine
awards where do we start you get into
the wine business you're in it for what
three months but six weeks six weeks and
you've already won an award and I tasted
this you were kind enough to send me a
bottle it was the red a cab merlot and
tell us about the award let's be fair
John it's been two years making you know
what's really blowing me away about
Ontario wines for the last twenty is we
were considered a backwater when you
talked about growing red vintages you
know I swine has some success globally
but no one ever talked about great
Cabernets or company prompt or Merlot
and Ontario and because slowly our
climates change and our ventures have
become very sophisticated in choosing
the right line we now have world-class
wines of Ontario so much so that we're
winning global awards yes it's true the
O'Leary Cabernet was chosen as the only
Canadian renamon teen hundred different
wines around the world I'm really proud
of it and the good news is its price to
1495 and available in every else to do
across the problem well I think in order
to make people feel better if I'm
remembering correctly from the label
your picture is not on the lake right oh
no just one game is all about your
picture my dilemma is you know I want a
great blast the one that I don't have to
pay a hundred dollars for that's what I
was working for and I think I've
achieved it another speaks though I'm
really proud of it look at ontario red
winning international awards nothing
wrong with that no that's right and i
saw the list and their wine from spain
chile italy all over the place and as
you say the O'Leary red one the best
value award from the inter van
International Wine Awards so good for
you and good for them and good for the
vendor which one is it the basic with
these vile an estate but I really have
to do a shout-out because those guys
have worked so hard over the last 20
years the schmidts brothers to compete
globally now they're getting your
accolade and I'm happy to be their part
and it's a fantastic place as you I'm
sure no to go for lunch you know you
feel like you're in a vineyard in France
don't you when you have lunch there oh
it's a beautiful place really proud to
be partnering with so we're going to do
a lot of stuff together you're going to
see a lot of wines you Larry name on in
the future